welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast I'm the new host and my name is
Gus Docker the nuclear arsenals of the
world are controlled by complex systems
and if these systems fail billions of
lives around the world are in danger so
on this episode of the podcast I talk
with Philip Reiner about what he's
learned about these systems throughout
his decades-long careers spanning the
White House the Pentagon and now as CEO
of the institute for security and
Technology we talk about how these
systems work how they might fail and
what we could do to improve them towards
the end of the episode Philip also
shares his thoughts about what's going
on in Ukraine and what this means for
nuclear risk Philip welcome to the
podcast thank you for having me it's
great to be here
what are nc3s
all right so
it it nuclear command control in
Communications right so in C3 this is
actually
a fairly American way of referring to
the systems that are in place that allow
for the management of nuclear operations
and so it's really
um in C3 in and of itself is a very
American characterization of what all
nuclear weapon states have to maintain
in order to ensure that
they are one able to utilize their
nuclear arsenals when they need to
but then also that
um
those systems won't
be used for nefarious purposes when they
aren't
being turned to for actual time nuclear
deployment so it's fairly uh complex
really often what we describe it as is
the fourth leg
of the nuclear Triad where you've got
the
um the elements that actually so nc3 are
probably the easiest way to summarize it
is that nc3 is the means by which
uh presidential Authority
is executed
and I think it's it's really important
to to note here right
as an American as a former Pentagon
official as a former White House
official that is the way we think of it
here in the United States
other nuclear weapon states don't
necessarily think of it in those in
those same terms how do other states
think about nc3s then yeah it's um
it's very much dependent upon the nation
and the
um
the kind of the history and the culture
that we're thinking of right
um each approaches it in in very much
their own way
um I I think it's also worth noting
actually if you look back at the history
of nc3 in the United States you can find
probably 15 different variations on the
characterization right where it's it's
in C2 it's tin C3 it's nc3i it's in
three or nc3 all of these other acronyms
that collusion all the different
components
of of what goes into the system of
systems that is in C3 I think
um it's very much contingent on
you know for instance you think about
okay I'll give the example of the UK
they have a submarine based deterrent
they're in C3 is going to be vastly
different than that is what is required
here in the United States if you look at
her say
Pakistan
a smaller Arsenal much different command
Authority in terms of who's actually in
charge of the maintenance and
utilization of these things in the in
the lead up to a conflict
military versus civilian all of those
sorts of of elements result in a
different command control architecture
I would argue that the United States
probably has
I think it's safe to say one of the most
sophisticated and complex systems of
systems when it comes to nc3 and you
know we've done some
some work on this at IST it's uh
we've seen that there are over you know
200 different systems within the nc3
system
and so when you speak of in C3 it's not
one monolithic thing right it's actually
all these other incredible components
right like signals processing
uh data data analytics lots of the
communication elements so
um it's very different say for North
Korea
right which is only a nascent
nuclear state where
um again they haven't had the Decades of
thinking through these sorts of
challenges like the United States has or
say Russia has
when we're thinking about the technology
involved in nc3 systems
what technology is involved at this
point because I think I have heard or
read rumors that the technology involved
is often very old but that there might
be reasons for having old technology
yeah yeah anything that's a um
it's an interesting conundrum right
where you find so the United States
over time there has developed a command
structure where you've got U.S strategic
command has leadership and ownership of
vast components of the nc3 architecture
and at the end of the manages our
nuclear forces right
I have heard
a strategic command Commander say
that at this point in its history the
development of usnc3 Might necessitate a
reversion to analog
in certain elements because of the risks
inherent to going digital right anybody
who spends time in this domain we uh we
often assert and I think it's fairly
commonly accepted at this point assume
breach
that you have digital systems they're
they're vulnerable it's almost an
inherent element from the Silicon all
the way up
um that someone is going to find a way
to to mess with and or break into your
systems and so
when thinking about something as
sensitive right something as uh
inherently dangerous as nuclear weapons
you have to very carefully think about
what you're going to digitize whether
it's the communications elements or
whether it's the actual command control
elements now
some countries have more
um
resources when it comes to that sort of
thing right when you think about
um say again Pakistan they may have the
imperative to move much more quickly
towards systems that give them more
immediate capability without having the
luxury
right they feel that imminent risk they
perceive that imminent risk from India
so they'll move down a path that allows
them to be able to
perhaps necessitate their digital
digitization up their system so that
they could be more able to move quickly
or communicate more rapidly but what has
that created in terms of the
vulnerabilities inherent to those those
systems they rely on so there is a real
trade-off and Analysis that needs to go
into
um any sort of of command and control
architecture now it goes without saying
right any system that relies on
Legacy components is going to need
to be not only maintained but probably
be retrofitted updated at some point
and so what we see in the United States
is and I think this goes for for Russia
very much so at the same time
this is a vast architecture that was
developed over the course of decades
right since the 19 really since the
early 1850s
and many of the integral components of
this as the you know the combatant
commander has talked about publicly
aren't up to Snuff these components are
being built anymore
you can't update something that's right
that's degrading in its uh in its
Effectiveness or in its functionality if
if no one's even building those parts
anymore right so
what's your what which way do you head
with that as you think about
um
the fact is right you need to have
this system needs to be available to you
at all times
right this is that always never Paradox
with with nuclear weapons right they
always need to be ready for you to use
in the case of a crisis where you need
to actually potentially deter an
adversary but you never want them to
actually you know be used nefariously
um and I think that's again that's often
when when folks talk about nuclear
weapons they they skip right past the
nc3 piece of it
which is almost if not more important
than any other element because of of
some of the questions you just asked
when it comes to the technological limit
I think
you know much of the conversation that
we've been involved with lately is
around
um
is around machine learning is is around
deep learning and it's potential role in
in modernization of nc3 architectures
I think the
the they're much you know much debate
around not just the integration of those
sorts of capabilities but also that the
automation
of certain decision elements within an
nc3 architecture that's a yeah it's a
very risk debate that gets back to the
technical uh at its core very very much
so
I'm wondering whether there are
trade-offs between speed of
implementation and security of the
resultant system of the system that that
we built in the end so you mentioned the
dilemma of that Pakistan is in where
they are building up capacity but do not
have the we could call it luxury of
building out Security in the same in the
same instance so how do you think about
this trade-off between security and
speed
it is a
um
it is a lesson that we've discussed in
great detail for instance with uh
counterpart of ours the the former head
of of security and privacy at Google
Eric gross ooh you know reminds us all
of this adage of complexity is the enemy
of security
and these these nc3 systems are so
incredibly complex that that even the
commander right of U.S strategic command
has noted publicly that even he doesn't
really understand how it all works
like looking at the vastness of the
system and understanding all the
interconnected components
at the end of the day though even you
know 20 some odd 30 some odd years ago I
think you had the the US National
Security advisor publicly saying he had
three minutes
to figure out what he was being told and
to take it to the president who would
then have four minutes
and that has that cycle that time
compression has only intensified
over the years since then so that
question that you note of speed
right is absolutely an imperative in a
world where
those sorts of risks
um are what you face I think a lot of
the work that has been done and it
continues to be push now is how do we
actually
extend those time Cycles
how do we actually build in more space
so that
those decision makers can actually have
more freedom to think and just debate
and and not have to rush to to deploy or
or potentially even use these and so
that it's a real conundrum right because
you have to have these systems in place
in order to move quickly
the quickest right you have to be able
to move faster than your adversary and
I'll let me come back to that it's not
just to maintain an advantage right so
let's come back to that in a second
um but you also need to take into
account that
um
that piece that you were talking about
right where it's you're moving so you
quickly down the path of adopting these
kinds of technologies that you're
actually making yourself less safe
you're actually making the entire
Dynamic less stable what could be an
example of moving too fast so that
you're making yourself a less safe well
I think the
um
a very clear example that one could
point to is
um
Russian indications that they're moving
down the path of having an automated
autonomous nuclear torpedo
right and the realistic nature of those
Technologies and whether or not they'll
get to a point that they can develop it
and deploy it as a you know debate I
don't know that that's necessarily look
at Ukraine
um some of what you know everyone
assumed Russia was going to be capable
it was actually a bit of a paper tiger
um
but their insinuation right is that they
want to be able to move down that path
so that they can have something that's
basically on not only hair trigger but
it's it's off of you know the United
States coastline
it is you know an immediate
nuclear risk to U.S not only military
but also civilian infrastructure
that speed that that tightening of then
and the coupling of all of those
decision-making elements is
I think their reaction to what they see
as a disadvantage vis-a-vis the United
States technologically and even more
broadly right economically Etc and so
they'll revert to the adoption of these
capabilities so that they can get inside
of our decision cycle that's that's
inherently destabilizing that is
inherently putting them
so that then forces and we saw this play
out in 2018 as this I think of 2018
where this became public 2019. the us
then starts to make changes in order to
react to that sort of behavior on the
Russian side which actually probably at
the end of the day makes Russia less
safe we're going to take steps in order
to
remove the threat posed by that by that
system
um
to what we were saying a second ago
right in terms of of the the importance
inherent to these things
one of the lessons of the Cold War was
the ability to actually
communicate with with your adversar so
the United States and USSR at the time
were able to actually have in-depth
conversations and
had understand to a great degree what
the other was capable of
right and so the speed at which you
could move
was something that you actually
discussed and put on the table
and there's a reason for that which is
that I am I'm looking to deter you
from moving first right bolt out of the
blue nuclear strikes are not something
that folks really
are super worried about today but this
was a very real
that was very realistic back in right
we're both out of the blue meaning like
someone who could just
unknown like out of nowhere strike you
and basically wipe you out so that you
have no ability to strike back
there is an imperative
right and it's somewhat counterintuitive
there is an imperative then if you're
the United States or Russia to be able
to prove that you can
survive
a nuclear strike and Strike Back
in order to deter
said
you know first strike inclination
yeah that's messy right like
you you're you're basically telling me
that you need to have more nuclear
weapons in order to prevent nuclear war
and you need to have the systems in
place in order to ensure that not just
have the nuclear weapons right but
ensure that those weapons will work
after there's a nuclear strike
when you update and maintain these
systems you then incentivize other
states to also update and maintain their
systems in a in a cycle of escalation
where no country is interested in in
escalating but all countries are
incentivized to escalate which is a you
know this is the the security dilemma
right I I do this is goes back thousands
of years right I do the things that I
see that are going to make me safer but
in the in the end they actually make me
less safe
it is a
um
that this is not something that's even
ever been solved and I don't know that
it ever will be right I think what's
interesting about it C3 though that is
often overlooked though is
if
you head down that path
it is it is a bit of a of a
contradictory scenario but if you are
able to head down a path and I'm
convinced of this
where you can actually show that your
systems are reliable
and resilient
and that they do the things that they're
supposed to do that is actually
inherently stabilizing
that is actually a let's say if you're
Indian Pakistan
and there isn't a whole lot of clarity
as to how the systems will perform and
whether decision makers will be able to
rely on their systems when they need to
that that is an inherently destabilizing
reality and so you actually want states
to be able to move down a path and again
not everybody uses the characterization
of nc3 but you I would argue we should
we should really do everything within
our power to ensure that states have
these capabilities
so that that risk of initial use goes
way down
it's even further kind of
counterintuitive in my opinion I think
that this is often again not not
something that's discussed very broadly
nc3 systems incredibly reliable in C3
systems actually could help reduce
nuclear arsenals
so we could actually see a world with
less nuclear weapons in it if you can
actually make sure that these nc3
systems are actually going to work in
the way that they're supposed to
if you think about at the end of the
Cold War that was one of the things that
actually allowed some of the dramatic
reductions in nuclear warheads
because you could point to systems that
would actually be more reliable and more
resilient therein you don't need as many
weapons
right because you've got this Arc it's
actually a confidence building measure
which
is entirely counter two or first right
really you're going to build out your
ability to to effectively and precisely
use nuclear weapons that's a that's a
stable yeah yeah it can actually be
inherent stabilizing so
um that's one of the reasons why you
look at something like or the situation
for instance in North Korea
but one of the reasons why it's so
frightening is they don't have these
sorts of systems they don't have the
commanded control and positive and
negative controls
that we would really hope for in a
nuclear weapon state to make sure that
things don't go wrong that those access
don't happen Etc
other ways to selectively enhance safety
in a nc3 systems as opposed to enhancing
both States the and capability
yeah it's a it's a fascinating question
I think
um
yeah absolutely yeah I think there are
both positive and negative controls that
can be decided upon that that will
improve
The credibility and the reliability of
these systems without necessarily giving
up uh
um some sort of of military
um
capability that would would be
destabilizing yeah absolutely I think
there's
um there's lists of things that that you
could go through and that could be part
of a of a conference building exercise
and I think the United States and Russia
perks the United States of the Soviet
Union went through that uh back during
the Cold War where they actually had
discussions about what are the types of
things that they were working toward and
what would they stay away from
yeah absolutely I think that is possible
I think the
you know necessity is the mother of all
invention right
um
that was because there were you know
tens of thousands of nuclear warheads
pointing at each other
and it was you know in imperative to
have those dialogues
a lot of that
sort of political space is a little bit
harder to imagine today
um one could take the unilateral steps
of heading in that path and think to a
certain degree the United States chooses
to do so
um
it's a it's somewhat further afield but
I think it's a good example of the US
unilateral announcement that they would
not develop uh ASAP capabilities
you know these are the kinds of things
that could factor into because that's
you know at the end of the day that's
part of your your command and control
architecture and your satellite your
infrastructure what are these
capabilities you just mentioned
in terms of the of the ASAP testing yeah
yeah well that this was a unilateral
movement the United States this part it
was actually announced by the vice
president that the United States if I'm
getting it right the United States would
not
um pursue the development of
anti-satellite
Technologies right that we would
um
tape off the table the development of
our ability to knock others satellites
out of you know to destroy their
satellite infrastructure we've seen
rather
um
sophisticated moves in that direction by
the Chinese by way example in recent
years and so this was a move on the
United States part to say we're going to
set a norm
that actually moves in the opposite
direction
you know there are there are those
within I think the U.S system who would
very ardently argue that that's
incredibly risky
to unilaterally move in that direction
but this the Biden Administration has
has done so and is now working as far as
I understand it working very earnestly
at the U.N to to establish this as a as
a norm that others are supportive of to
try and move away from that because of
all the risks
inherent to having those kinds of
Technologies
these unilateral de-escalation moves are
they a general solution to the security
problem
it's it's one tool right it's it's one
means of
um engaging in these sorts of confidence
building steps there's there's
unilateral there's many lateral the
multilateral there's bilateral there's
there's a broad bright broad variety of
ways that you can
uh try to come at these sorts of
Dynamics and and you know put ideas on
the table that will help reduce
pressure reduce risk enhance uh Trust
I I think this is
uh what allowed things to what allowed
for you know avoidance of nuclear war
during the Cold War
it's one of the things you know I'm
someone who has spent a large
uh chunk of my professional career
working on South Asia so with everyone
in the India Pakistan Dynamic and you
know Finding cbm's
in that space that
um both nations are able and willing to
talk about it's been it's been years
so if you can even get that stuff on the
table it's tough
we should talk about the communication
part of nc3 it seems to me that
commutation is an almost pure good in
these situations if states can
communicate more with each other it
seems uh perfectly great yeah what do
you think of that is it is it the case
that communication more communication is
always better or is or could there be
downsides to having States communicate
more effectively with each other
one of the things that we have spent a
great deal of time on at IST is thinking
about
crisis Communications and crisis
communication Solutions
and this harks back to something I
mentioned earlier from with Eric gross
from the former
security from Google something we've
been thinking about is this catalink
system
which is a um
it's an attempt to to Pivot off of this
idea that complexity is the enemy of
security
so how do you actually build a a very
robust resilient Communications
capability that is available
to all nuclear heads of state
to avoid crisis
and so this I think for your question
this is predicated off of the
um the hypothesis that the ability to
communicate with one another is
absolutely a good thing
I think the the history of hotlines if
you if you go back to
uh nuclear hotlines right there's
there's all sorts of different types of
others military and Military hotlines
there's all sorts of different types of
hot lines that historically have played
a role in in reducing conflict but if
you think about nuclear hotlines you'd
look back to what happened after the
Cuban Missile Crisis
in the U.S Russia
excuse me U.S Soviet uh hotline that was
established after that
there were you know there were times
when political actors attempted to use
that Hotline in a in a negative way
were they attempted to manipulate it and
you know manipulate their their
counterparts so you know there's a
there's an element of trust here that
that is really necessary for
those Communications channels to to be
effective
if you
um
if you also you know look at
the current Dynamics say with with China
they want to pick up the phone
so even if you do have the system in
place it's trust it it's reliable secure
the other you know the folks on the
other end need to to be authorized to
actually pick up and and speak or
communicate whatever it would text based
or phone-based or whatever it might be
without a doubt the ability to
communicate with one another reduces
risk the ability to actually understand
where the other person is coming from
reduces reduces risk I think I always
look back to my time at the White House
when you know we would go through Cycles
where we wouldn't be able to meet with
our counterparts
and you know go months six months at a
time and and just being able to go sit
down
with your counterparts would
it would change it would just change
this Dynamic almost immediately
um you look at how long for instance you
know the Xi Jinping
um from China didn't leave the country
that's that's incredibly worrying but
you have got to be able to sit down
you've got to have communication and in
today's world there are all sorts of
different ways to communicate with one
another I think
relying on you know WhatsApp may not
necessarily be what you want nuclear
heads of you know heads of state you
know turning to in order to communicate
with one another so that's why
we've come up with this idea
a catalink maybe that could be additive
to existing command and control system
additive to existing Communications
capabilities but um
without any doubt yeah having the
ability to to communicate with one
another is absolutely essential to to
reducing risk
could you tell us more about the current
situation of communications between
nuclear states is it actually the case
that they are communicating using
Whatsapp
well you know I think
um
there's all variety of different you
know secure messaging platforms that
folks have become reliant on in both
diplomatic circles and elsewhere it's
I WhatsApp tends to be the one you hear
most often about folks you know engaging
in conversation via I think
um
there is
a a real challenge in terms of so
there's the day-to-day there's contents
you know diplomatic negotiations that
may be happening over those types of
platforms but then there's the level of
things work that we're talking about
when a crisis may actually be maybe
Brewing
and what sorts of communications
capabilities do you have in place and
there is a very reliable hotline between
the United States and Russia
it is not only at the head of state
level but there are means of
communication for potentially the the
secretary of defense or the United
States to talk to his counterpart
um
what we've seized upon in this
um current situation current reality is
that those tend to be
not tend to be those are solely
bilateral means of communication
but we don't live in a bilateral reality
so if there is a potential nuclear
crisis like what we've seen kind of as a
result of what's going on in Ukraine
that is not a U.S Russia problem
you've got two other nuclear-armed
states in the midst of that situation
with France in the UK
not to mention the fact that China is
almost guaranteed to be a part of that
um situation if if Russia were to
actually use nuclear weapons against
Ukraine
how are all of those States going to be
able to communicate with each other well
it's all bilateral if at all
I think one of the very interesting
things that was brought to our attention
was that the ability for
even for you know NATO Russia and the UK
or NATO Russia and France to be able to
communicate with each other
simultaneously doesn't exist
you think about that right you you've
got a group chat on Signal with folks in
seven different countries and you guys
can just you can have a totally
encrypted no one's ever going to know
what's in that discussion
means of communicating with each other
but we can't we currently don't have
that means for heads of state from with
states with nuclear weapons that's
that's
Beyond Simple to get after that
challenge in in our opinion so
I I think you know folks May default to
Whatsapp because it's what's in their
pocket so why don't why don't we work on
giving them something else that they
could rely on that's more secure and and
robust and dedicated
right distinctly built and dedicated to
this sort of challenge because
you know maybe what's happened can
signal serve a purpose all the
day-to-day but we'd need something a
little bit more
um
like dedicated and robust for for these
kinds of challenges that's what the
catalytic system is trying to get after
let's walk through the different parts
of the catalink system and then you
could tell us what the different parts
of the of this system what problems are
solved by these parts
so the the basics right of of catalan's
really three primary components there's
a
there's a device we call it the puck
and that's the the communication device
that you would rely on it's a basic text
based messaging capability that is
um built from the bottom up again this
notion of complexity is the enemy of
security having worked with
uh Folks at Google and Intel
um and and elsewhere to think about how
do you actually build something from the
bottom up from the Silicon up that is
actually verifiably secure
so that's the the puck then there's a
what uh we call the broker so this is
the interface
from
through which the signals from the puck
would be uh translated into whatever
sort of communications Network you
relying
and the way that we're designing this is
so that I mean that is very flexible
that you can actually determine through
which whatever mechanism you want those
messages to actually go whether that be
satellite based or cell based what have
you
um so that's redundancy in the network
that transmits these messages inherently
this is where it gets most interesting
though right because and Incredibly
challenging in the uh event where you
actually have an exchange a nuclear
exchange and or even in the lead-up to
an exchange
um what you'll see in the most planning
and you saw this to a certain degree
just with with Ukraine Communications
architectures are what are going to be
targeted first
almost 100 of the time whether that be
the satellite Network the cell towers
the internet
the ability to get information through
is going to be one of the first victims
and lead up to any conflict
so if you're relying on this
multinational
catalytic system what is your fallback
for kids and when those other options
are not available to you and that's the
third component that we've been working
on we call it the rocks
um it is the intention is to build up
a mesh Network that will be available
when everything else fails
and so that is honestly it's an
incredibly complex
technical challenge to to get after it's
something we're working on we love to
hear from people who who work on these
kinds of things already and who will be
interested in playing a part of of any
of these pieces I think one of the
two two or three things about this that
that we've been getting after that sets
it apart I think from other other ideas
that are out there the idea is that
we'll we'll do it in the in the code for
the puck is actually up on GitHub that
the Eric has already been working on and
has put up
um on GitHub if folks are interested
they can they can come to us and we can
point them toward it we want this to be
open we want this to be transparent and
we want this to be something that folks
really around the world can work on
together
so that it actually is trusted and that
it has integrity and that it's resilient
right so folks can hack on it together
and actually really try to break it
um that's a big part of what we're
trying to do I think one of the other
pieces is we've worked with Folks at
galwa
uh who do formal methods to think about
how to actually you know prove some that
something does what it's supposed to do
and so get annual coin work with the
code for the puck and the broker so that
we can run it through that sort of uh
verification process is actually an
integral part of this as well
um lastly I think one of the most
important things and this is what we've
talked about with representatives from
various
States is we have no interest in
imposing this on somebody else
we'll develop it and then you take it
integrate it into your systems however
you see fit
I'm not going to tell you what Hardware
to use I'm not going to tell you how you
need to build it into your architecture
those are things that you can figure out
therein you would trust it even more
because it's something that you had to
figure out on your own how to actually
do we'll build the architecture we'll
explain to you how to do it but then you
can run with it I think that's an
attempt on our part to kind of break
with with tradition a little bit I think
um
in doing so though we'll build more
trust and interest in participating uh
by each of the states that are concerned
the code is open source and
States might be able to verify that the
code does what it says it does what
about the hardware level could could
other states be worried that the
hardware has been tampered with and that
the is that this system is therefore not
to be trusted for sure and that's one of
the things that we uh then this is just
kind of a little bit to an extent of
what I was just referring to I think the
the
idea is that states will take this and
they can pick and use their own Hardware
uh we we've had that very Frank
conversation with a number of of
the leaders from from states that have
nuclear weapons and have made very clear
that we
you know we work with folks who are
building fairly secure
um devices from the bottom up but we
wouldn't necessarily say that that's
what you have to use this would be
something that you can take and you can
integrate into your own systems you pick
your own Hardware so that you you can
trust it to I'd most agree that that's
absolutely something that we talk about
um
I think trying to impose
some form of hardware on folks it's just
it's not going to go anywhere so we
really want to leave that up to to the
states themselves
what prevents Catalin the Catalyst link
system from being implemented
I think there's a we've gotten a great
deal so we now have a support and
funding from the uh the government of
Switzerland and from the uh the
government of Germany and we're very
proud and happy to be working with them
both on the political but also the
technical level and extremely uh
grateful for their support I think the
the conversations by way of the example
that we had when we were up at the uh
review conference for the npt up in New
York we're incredibly encouraging
in terms of the states that
um are supportive of this as a tangible
example of of risk reduction
the
really it's it's just the hard work of
speaking to those who would need to use
it so that they get involved and and
move from kind of this idea
prototype phase into its actual
implementation
it is arguably
less a technical question
as it is more a political question
I think it's fair to say that you know
any state with nuclear weapons as soon
as you start talking to them about
giving them Communications capabilities
that involve nuclear decision making
they're they're going to be somewhat
incredulous right at the notion that
what so this this NGO in California has
come up with some device that I want to
give the president
to use any situations well yeah that's
that's the idea and that we we try to
leverage some of the capabilities of
these technical communities to to solve
really what is kind of a
in my opinion what is a market failure
this is not a problem that folks haven't
known about this has been a
long-standing challenge that if you look
back at uh
some of the literature from the 1980s I
think it was an unedited volume that
that Ash Carter and others put forward
in 1987. this this came up multiple
times in there how do you actually
communicate in the midst of a crisis
with your adversary
when everything's being destroyed
we don't talk enough about that part of
risk reduction
and so I said you know I think we've
we've seen some great success in our in
our conversations today I think
honestly the the biggest thing between
here and there is is just continuing to
Galvanize support for it and get the
get the support from the technical end
of Build It Out The Rock's piece in
particular
to build this out so that folks can turn
to it and actually start thinking about
how to integrate it
let's talk about the role of artificial
intelligence in nuclear command
um control and communication systems to
to what extent is nuke is AI being used
today in these systems
I think the you know the the literature
that's out there around these things
points to the use of
um
technical capabilities that I think
folks today don't even really think of
as artificial intelligence right
going back decades to for signals
processing and
um data aggregation you know there were
tools that were deployed probably I
would argue in that in the 70s that at
the time were referred to as artificial
intelligence right but folks wouldn't
even think of it that way anymore
I think what you're more getting at is
the kind of conversation around machine
learning deep learning and its potential
integration into these systems there are
all number of conversations around
the relative merits of of integrating
these capabilities into nuclear command
control Communications and I think the
there was an article that came out
um probably 2019
2018 from uh Curtis mcgiven
um
and uh
I can't remember his kind of person's
name The the article basically made the
argument that the United States needs to
develop and deploy a dead hand
uh system right so this this uh
automated system that would be
responsive and launch a nuclear attack
if a state were to be you know decapped
in and the signals could not the
messages could not get through Etc
and the
the thing that we
um spoke about at a time when that came
out was to have
two folks write that article who
probably have been involved in related
conversations
in classified circles
right what you
um
almost have to assume there is that
there are conversations around that
sort of there are debates around that
sort of thing but then classified
circles and so you you begin to wonder
to what extent is it really being
considered
and
um I think it's safe to say that at this
point at least to my knowledge
the the considerations I don't know it's
really very much opaque right I don't
know the extent to which folks are
moving down that path
but it gets to some of the questions
that you were asking earlier in terms of
that
tightening decision cycle in which you
need to be able to move quickly
and I think what's important here to
think about right when you look at the
signaling for instance again we talked
about it a little bit from the Russian
side in terms of the capabilities
they're they're discussing
um
you look at what Russia talks about you
look at what China
is signaling that its intentions are
when it comes to command and control and
artificial intelligence
um
supported
system decision support systems Etc that
they're heading down that path
in that they are looking for advantages
to be gained
by deploying machine learning
capabilities deep learning capabilities
into
all variety of command and control
related
sub components
and so there you are in that Dynamic
again right if the United States sees
China heading down that path and it's
not entirely clear
where they are in their capabilities
today where they might be in a few years
you're you're you're almost being
irresponsible to not head down that same
path to figure out what you're capable
of and what you may need to be doing in
order to
stay ahead and toward deter
another Nation from from getting ahead
of you or putting you at risk so you
know to your question it's it's
something that is I think getting a lot
of attention or a lot of discussion I
think one of the pieces that's
that we've pointed to is the discussion
at least the public discussion has not
been very specific
it's been very broad right artificial
intelligence what are you talking about
specifically nuclear command and control
and communication well what what are you
talking about
again you know early in the conversation
I noted there's there's over 200
subsystems within the US and C3 system
of systems where does deep learning even
factor into that
potentially
we've we've gone through the lists of
the sub components that are at least
publicly known
and I think there's a small not small
it's not it's not insignificant the the
number of sub-components that could
potentially be enhanced by integrating
machine learning capabilities in terms
of
signal modulation or um what have you I
think there are definite
advantages to to moving down that path
I think what folks tend to think about
is the automation
of end launch decisions
so at this point
we have not seen any indication
from the United States by way of example
that they're heading down a path like
not quite the opposite
they continue to publicly State and
indicate that they will not turn those
sorts of decisions over to machines
um how however powerful those machines
become
that's a little less clear when it comes
to to Russia and China to be quite
honest it's it's not as clearly stated
um and some of their activities would
would point to otherwise to to be honest
so and how could this be dangerous so
how could geosing AI in in nc3 systems
be dangerous I'm thinking about these
systems could be unreliable they might
be open to being hacked
um
yeah how could it be dangerous to
implement AI in in nc3s
which time do you have
um
it's a
there's so many layers to the risks that
that are adherent to this and I think
um
absolutely for what you were just saying
there is that for and again we talked
about this earlier right digital systems
are almost inherently vulnerable
and I think you know folks out there
working on AI red teams
will tell you that you know machine
Learning Systems inherit in inherit
cyber vulnerabilities
that have not been solved elsewhere
right and so that is that is not
something that can be
uh easily dismissed or overlooked you
I think
you have to think about
a more strategically this is the way I
I've given lectures on this at UC
Berkeley actually there's basically
three tiers of consideration you need to
to give this when when thinking about
the risk that it that it introduces
the Strategic the operational and the
Tactical
right so we were just talking about the
Tactical level considerations that you
need to put which is
perturbations like somebody's messing
with a model and you're getting
information out of that model that's
telling you one thing that's actually
completely
um not accurate
how do you actually deal with that
in a system of systems that is so
complex
that you're not even entirely clear on
what your system is
right so you're introducing the
a vulnerability a layer of risk that is
difficult to actually ascertain
that's
technical that's the most scientific at
its course maybe you can get after the
error rates that then compound within
that stack
and better understand it and then have a
conversation with your adversary about
that
that's pretty tough just in and of
itself right but then you start thinking
about the operational level
these are incredibly tightly coupled
systems
right so what I mean by that right is
that
signal decision action has to be so
tight
that you don't really have time to stop
and say
um
yesterday was uh Petrov day right
this is an individual who was receiving
signals and warning through automated
means
telling him that there was an incoming
ballistic missile attack from the United
States
okay I forget what year this was right
but Petrov said no that's incredible
that's no way
but there's no way that's happening and
he stood things down right
um
this is
the inherent risk when you have systems
that are so tightly comfortable they're
going to be accidents there's going to
be errors they're going to be false flag
false negatives
there's going to be
uh mistakes
and when you introduce black box systems
or systems that are incredibly brittle
or systems that are overfitted or
systems that you know all these other
problems that really haven't been
figured out when these systems are in
the wild you begin to have operational
level considerations of risk that
even when it comes to like
airline industry they haven't entirely
wrapped their heads around or autonomous
vehicles writlock driving I think
there's a lot of emergent properties to
those systems that folks never
anticipated
that's something you need to Grapple
with and then of course what we talked
about earlier in the in the
podcast in terms of the Strategic level
considerations
you are watching me I'm watching you
the signaling that takes place and The
credibility that's necessary with
nuclear command control Communications
that I am going to be able to do what I
say I'm going to be able to do
I trust that you are and if those things
are inherently unsound
and unreliable
that's inherently destabilizing and so
as we head down a path where these sorts
of capabilities might be integrated into
nuclear command and control
how do you actually create transparency
how do you actually create dialogue at a
senior level so that folks can reduce
that sort of strategic level risk
that's that's very very difficult
um so yeah it needs to say it uh
the conversations that we've been a part
of you know what it has often said
that the benefits do out do not outweigh
the risks
you haven't figured out the the answers
to the problems enough to be able to
head down that path and it doesn't
really give you that much more of an
advantage
uh in the end but there are others who
would argue against that and say that it
does that it actually gives you
know capabilities that are really Beyond
even more comprehension at this point
you would definitely have to drive down
the error rate of these automated
systems to an unprecedented level that's
right much much lower than in
self-driving cars for example yeah and
we've seen that this is very extremely
difficult to do
um yeah yeah
I would like to to touch upon the
conflict between Russia and Ukraine
um because I think this is on on the top
of people's mind when we're talking
about uh the risk of of using nuclear
weapons right now
what is your overall take on on how this
Roar how this war has changed uh the
risk of of nuclear weapons use
I think at its core it's been deeply
unsettling
I the you know as someone who has spent
decades
working with and around and on these
sorts of
challenges
when when you think about nuclear
deterrence and you think about the risk
of nuclear weapons how violent and
catastrophically violent they are
um
I think we we often lose touch
with
with
the actual impact that the use of these
would have
and we find ourselves in a in a
generational shift
where I think a lot of leaders and
decision makers even within the system
today
seem to be increasingly and collided to
work thinking about
nuclear war fighting has an option and
that's deeply concerning because we're
moving toward in my opinion we're moving
toward a world with more nuclear weapons
and more nuclear weapons States
um
to all of everything we've talked about
here within C3 today becomes all that
much more important as you see a world
with with more states of nuclear weapons
what we've seen from the the really
awful and almost abhorrent not almost
absolutely according situation in
Ukraine is
this is one of the the real
long-standing
um
challenges when it comes to to just
having nuclear reps in the deterrent
purpose that they're supposed to serve
and what we've seen is is Russia's
willingness coinlessly to break
a number of long-standing norms that it
had been committed to
your I.E nuclear assurances for for
Ukraine that having given up its nuclear
Arsenal that it would not be put at risk
like this
what does that signal to other states
that are considering moving down this
path
uh Russia Russia's willingness to to you
know talk about and you know now they're
in the Motions of going through these
referenda and you know annexing
Ukraine's territory so that you know
once that's done and they say that
that's part of Russia
now they will say that attacks against
that territory could result in a nuclear
response
that is
you know this is this is
Beyond I think what anybody would have
accepted even just a few years ago as
acceptable behavior
it's an incredibly
risky and dangerous Dynamic and it's
moving the world in the direction
in a direction honestly that I never in
my life thought that I would that I
would see
um it's inherently unsettling to say the
least and then you see in Russia going
even further putting a nuclear power
plant basically in the middle of an
armed conflict and using it
um basically it's blackmail
a massive potential radiological weapon
you know almost in the heart of Europe
is
is reckless Beyond uh almost Beyond
imagination so yeah the
um I think it definitely
increases the the risk
all of that being said
again as someone who spent a lot of time
around these things over the years maybe
just maybe
this sort of Reckless
irresponsible State Behavior will result
positive outcomes
maybe this will actually motivate people
to change some of the trajectories that
we've been on maybe this will actually
point to the need to have greater
constraints in place maybe this will
actually Galvanize International actors
to
move more collaboratively toward making
clear that this sort of behavior is just
absolutely unacceptable
right so you think about I hate to say
it you think about the China Taiwan
dynamic
and what does this scenario mean for
that
I think it's the program and absolute
disgust and rejection of Russia's
actions in Ukraine by the International
Community
that matters
that speaks volume volumes to to the
leaders and decision makers in Beijing
and so
it is an incredibly critical situation
I I don't think I know well anyone who
tells you they know what Putin is going
to do is is
wine I don't think anybody really knows
what's gonna happen or how much he means
it
when he says he willing to use a
low-yield you know tactical nuclear
weapon in Ukraine to advance their their
objectives
um
hopefully this has positive outcomes but
at the end of the day
I think has Putin continues to
see as I mean as many have said as
President Putin sees increasing losses
and setbacks on the ground
that is an unacceptable
outcome
for him
it leaves him with very few options and
so this is where
you know the National Security advisor
has its has his work cut out for him in
advising President Biden on on what
decisions to to take and how far to push
and
how to make sure that we don't go too
far and you know push this
clearly
um embattled leader into a corner to the
point where he needs to make really
horrible decisions to deploy and use
nuclear weapons
if he did I don't know that any of us
understand just how much that will
change our world
how critical is the situation right now
compared to say the Cuban Missile Crisis
um
very different Dynamic right I think the
the lines of communication are are in
as far as when you tell very open
between the US and Russia that those
messages that we're sending are getting
through what whether or not they're
being heard is a completely different
thing
um
I think the
you know the fact is is that
um
in that instance in the Cuban Missile
Crisis that would have resulted in
very quickly
catastrophic nuclear use
I think in this situation you don't
necessarily see that you're going to see
you know if Russia were to actually move
down the path of of using
low yield perhaps low yield on nuclear
weapons against Ukraine the response
from NATO the response from the United
States and NATO
I don't know that it wouldn't
necessitate
a nuclear response
whereas an attack on the United States
would
right so it's a little bit of a
different Dynamic however
horrifying in uh and
escalatory that would be it the the
escalation ladder in that scenario is
not anything anyone has ever actually
had to live through
right we don't know yeah
it's an unknown situation it's an it's
an it's a situation the world has not
been in before so it's the imperative is
it is upon our leaders to to take all of
the inputs that they have and you know
hopefully they're not uh relying on a on
a on a brittle uh Predictive Analytics
platform
that is telling them what to do right
yeah this is uh this goes back to to the
risks of embedding you know automated
decision making support systems into
your nuclear chromatic drill you want to
be able to
to really retain that human element in
this sort of scenario to to think about
ways to fill in
uh de-escalation paths yeah
I can't say this has been a happy
conversation but it's been very
informative and scary also thank you for
talking with me absolutely my pleasure
thanks thanks for having me lots of work
to do that's it for this week's episode
on next week's episode we'll be looking
into how combining artificial
intelligence with nuclear command and
control systems could be dangerous and
we'll be looking into concrete scenarios
for how this could increase risk